for this family home is now a refugee
camp in Jordan they thought they would
be here for just a few weeks but for
years on they have no idea if they'll
ever go home it's attacks such as this
one in Aleppo a few days ago that forced
them to flee civilians are being killed
every day in Syria the war has already
claimed more than 200,000 lives and
destroyed the infrastructure of
countless towns the country is on the
brink of collapse these satellite images
from Twitter paint a dire picture Syria
in total darkness at night
this is a war with many enemies rebel
groups fight the Assad regime and each
other militants like Islamic state
benefit for this power vacuum and
control large areas of the country aid
organizations blame the international
community for failing to implement
humanitarian efforts to help refugees in
fact if you look across the indicators
which we've analyzed there's been more
killings more bombings massive increase
in displacement and a huge increase in
the number of people that are in need
inside in need of humanitarian
assistance inside silly half of Syria's
23 million inhabitants have fled to
neighboring countries like Lebanon where
they live in desperate conditions well I
hired we're entering the fifth year of
war and we ask ourselves is it possible
this is happening to us we're in one
place and their families in another they
can't reach us and we can't reach them
either through the UN or smugglers
there's no solution our suffering is
great for many Syrians the prospect of
returning home to normal life is
becoming a distant dream